bonsoir comme dont je fais en merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
les ressortissants français en ont-ils
vraiment intérêt à quitter
provisoirement le pakistan comme le
recommande l'ambassade française à
islamabad
il va en tout cas être très prudent de
mac puisque le mouvement qui regroupe
enfin qui a été interdite par le
gouvernement pakistanais a lancé un
nouveau mot d'ordre de manifestation
demain essentiellement à islamabad et
par conséquent il faut que les
ressortissants français soient très
prudent alors c'est vrai que les
autorités françaises leur ont demandé de
quitter le pakistan
temporairement ils sont pas très
nombreux et ils sont comme environ 450
inscrits dans nos deux consulats et la
plupart d'entre eux travaillent dans les
grandes entreprises qui sont d'ailleurs
dont l'activité n'est absolument pas
remise en cause et ses grandes
entreprises sont des employeurs de
nombreux pakistanais certains donc sont
déjà partis d'autres vents ont vraiment
en partir en ce qui concerne nos
compatriotes et je pense qu'ils doivent
rester très prudent tout état de cause
mais je pense que évidemment c'est un
peu un dilemme puisque certains d'entre
eux ne veulent pas quitter leur travail
qu' ils sont attachés à leur entreprise
et que d'ailleurs la présence française
et est assez faible au pakistan comparé
à la présence économique d'autres pays
occidentaux
alors où en sont les relations
diplomatiques entre la france et le
pakistan
alors il n'y a pas d'ambassadeur du
pakistan à à paris pour une raison de
circonstances le l'ancien ambassadeur
avait fini son mandat au mois d'août
dernier
il est parti et imran khan le premier
ministre pakistanais a négligé de nommer
tout de suite un nouvel ambassadeur
ensuite lorsque l' affaire a commencé
avec l' affaire des caricatures et bien
les mannequins à penser que pour apaiser
les choses il valait mieux différer la
nomination d'un ambassadeur pakistanais
à paris donc l'ambassade fonctionne sous
la direction d'un chargé d'affaires
pour ce qui est de notre ambassade à
islamabad eh bien le gouvernement
français a retiré 15 membres pour des
raisons de sécurité mais les chefs de
service continu est là l'ambassadeur
aussi et là encore la nacelle fonctionne
et sous la direction de l'ambassadeur
naturellement en prenant les mesures de
sécurité qui s'imposent sécurité qui en
fonction de conventions de genève est
assurée par le gouvernement pakistanais
à l'extérieur de l'ambassade et bien
entendu par des gendarmes à l'intérieur
de l'ambassade
pour le reste on a bien vu que le
mouvement islamiste radical qui est
interdite depuis le 16 novembre
concentre concentre son action sur
l'expulsion de l'ambassadeur de france
c'est sa demande principale il veut la
rupture des relations diplomatiques et
l'expulsion de lance de l'ambassadeur de
france
parce que il n'a pas accepté que charlie
et de re publie les caricatures au début
du mois de septembre les caricatures du
prophète au moment du de la deûle du
procès des attentats des attentats de
charlie hebdo précisément et il a encore
moins acceptée naturellement que le
président de la république française
disent que les caricatures était quelque
chose qui n'était pas question
d'interdire en france qui avait une
tradition française républicaine et que
par conséquent il n'est il interdirait
pas la publication de tels de telles
caricatures donc depuis bien ce
mouvement extrémiste
encore une fois interdit maintenant par
le gouvernement par le gouvernement
pakistanais
demande le départ de l'ambassadeur de
france alors on verra comment se déroule
la manifestation de demain
mais effectivement il faut être très
attentif
la situation peut-être tout peut tourner
très rapidement à des violences qui en a
eu il ya beaucoup à lahore et il ya eu
des morts des deux côtés
du côté de la police mais aussi du côté
des manifestants
les manifestants en tuant des policiers
en retenant en otage onze d'entre eux
pendant presque une journée entière se
sont mis hors la loi
par conséquent ils ont en principe
perdit l'appui du gouvernement jude et
de certains membres du gouvernement
pakistanais
si certains le soutenait et probablement
aussi les militaires dont on sait qu'ils
jouent un rôle clé au pakistan pour bien
qu'on comprenne changement de maison y
at-il une spécificité de ce pays
concernant l'apparition de mouvements
susceptibles de recourir à la violence
peut prendre quelques exemples on sait
que le pakistan a toujours été très lié
avec ce qui se passait en afghanistan et
que bien souvent il a servi de refuge
aux talibans
certains venant d'ailleurs s'entraîner
s'entraîner au pakistan deuxième exemple
les attentats de bombay qui ont fait
plus de 160 morts
avec d'ailleurs beaucoup d'étrangers de
touristes tuées dans ces attentats
et bien c'est un groupe qui venaient du
pakistan qui est venu par la mère qui
s'était entraîné au pakistan alors ça
n'était pas du tout le gouvernement qui
entraînait une enfin il avait trouvé
refuge au pakistan et les moyens pour
s'entraîner et à chaque fois qu'il ya un
attentat en inde que ce soit contre le
parlement
que ce soit contre des militaires ou des
paramilitaires et bien effectivement les
groupes terroristes viennent du pakistan
c'est à dire qu'ils y ont un refuge une
sorte de sanctuaire et par conséquent
ceux ci donnent une image un petit peu
particulière alors aujourd'hui
l affaire des caricatures de charlie
hebdo a provoqué aussi des réactions
dans d'autres pays musulmans mais elles
se sont calmées elles se sentent apaisés
au pakistan au nom parce que en effet un
certain nombre d'extrémistes
il voit là le moyen probablement d'avoir
eu de faire de croire aucune agitation
politique comme je le disais tout à
l'heure l'armée joue un rôle clé au
pakistan et notamment les services de
renseignement et fameux
yj et il est probable que l'isi est en
train de prendre parti sur cette affaire
et que probablement il a les moyens
d'éviter de nouveaux développements
violent venant de la part de ce groupe
extrémiste
merci beaucoup au club blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales